>> Nicole Chung: Good afternoon.
My name's Nicole Chung, and
I'm with "The Washington Post,"
which is a charter sponsor of
The National Book Festival.
First, a word of thanks for our
co-chairman of the festival,
David Rubenstein
[assumed spelling],
and the other generous sponsors
who've made this event possible.
If you'd like to add
your financial support,
please note the information
in your program.
We'll have some time after this
presentation for your questions,
and I've been asked to
remind you that if you come
to the microphone, you will
be included in the videotape
of this event, which may be
broadcast at a later date.
Our guest this afternoon
is Brendan Kiely,
who is an amazing young
adult author about books all
about love in different
shapes and forms.
His most recent book is
Tradition , and before that,
he was a co-author of
All American Boys with
Jason Reynolds.
In addition, he also wrote
The Last True Love Story .
And without further ado,
please welcome Brendan
Kiely to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> Brendan Kiely:
How's it going?
All right.
I can't see you at all,
so if I can hear you,
it just makes me feel like
I'm not alone in the room.
So I appreciate that.
Thanks, everyone.
It is such an honor
to be invited to speak
at The National Book Festival.
I think a lot about how
sometimes we read articles,
and they're, you
know, threatening.
Oh, you know, books are dying.
Publishing is dying.
People aren't reading.
And then you read other
articles, and you, I think,
have to look to young
folks, as we often do,
to think about how
there's so much passion
for so much literature
right now.
Especially as we think
about a publishing industry
that is ever-so-slowly thinking
about how to broaden the scope
of the kinds of stories that
we hear, the kinds of stories
that we publish, and
the kinds of stories
that have always existed
out there, and just needed
to be published to
a wider audience.
And so, for me to say all
this in context as being part
of The National Book Festival
I think is really important --
that we think about what it
means to be writing books
for the entire nation, and to
be thinking about what it means
to be part of that tradition, as
opposed to some other traditions
that I will get into
in a moment.
But before I talk
about tradition,
I want to just give you
a little bit of context
about Brendan Kiely,
and who I am,
and sort of where I come from,
and how I became a writer.
And to do that, I want to take
you back to my very first book,
which was called The
Gospel of Winter .
I'm from the Boston area,
and I grew up in an Irish
Catholic community, household,
big family, went to
Catholic schools.
And I was dismayed when
"The Boston Globe" broke the
news story on January 6th
of 2002 about the scandal of
abuse in the Catholic Church --
the vast cover-up of scandal --
of abuse in the Catholic Church.
I watched at dinner
table conversations
as family members would
go to war with each other,
some people saying, "This is
now a time to double-down,
and show our faith," other
people saying, "Now is the time
where I say good-bye
to this church,
and I never return ever again."
And to see families
at war with each other
in that way made me think
a lot about what it means
to be a young person
watching their families at war
in this way, or watching their
communities at war in this way.
And what does it mean to be
a young person who's trying
to navigate all of that
struggle and that strife?
And it was really important to
me, especially, because of all
that particular connection
that I had to that news story.
So when I wrote my book
The Gospel of Winter ,
which is about a 16-year-old
boy who's struggling
to decide whether or not he
should tell the world he's been
abused by his priest,
I was really nervous,
as you can imagine.
I was especially nervous what
my family would say, right?
"Brendan, you shouldn't be
talking about that stuff!"
Instead, I felt like I had to,
but I did one wise thing
while working on this book.
I gave an early copy to my
grandmother, the matriarch
of the family, Grandma Kiely.
We call her St. Jane in
the family [laughter],
and she is St. Jane
in so many ways.
And I was nervous.
What is Grandma going
to think of this book?
She wrote back to me after she'd
read the early advance copy
of the book, and she wrote
this note to me, by the way,
on Facebook -- Cyber
Grandma [laughter].
It was pretty remarkable
to receive her note,
because she said, "Brendan,
this book reminds me
of Solomon asking God
for a listening heart."
And I think about that line, and
I will probably choke up halfway
through saying this now.
I think about that line,
about what it means
to have a listening heart.
And I realized that Grandma
-- Grandma was, as always,
so much wiser than
I will ever be.
And she put to words what
I realized was my mission
in writing books for young
folks, writing books for adults,
writing books for anyone
who wants to think about --
how do we voice the
emotional experience of living
in communities that
feel like they're at war
with each other in so many ways?
Maybe what we need is to
find these listening hearts.
And so, I try to write books
with a listening heart,
and I try to write
books about people
who are discovering what it
means to look for and find,
and to embrace their
own listening hearts.
And so, the second book
that I wrote is called The
Last True Love Story ,
and of course, who do I
want to write this book for?
My grandmother, because
it was a story about --
in short, it's a story about
a family that's grappling
with a grandfather who
has Alzheimer's disease.
And I wrote that book because my
grandmother was there as a rock
as my grandfather was passing
away from Alzheimer's disease.
And The Last True Love
Story is about two teens
who spring an
Alzheimer's-afflicted
grandfather from an
assisted-living facility
in Los Angeles, and take him
on a cross-country road
trip to Ithaca, New York.
To the hill where he
first kissed his wife,
so that he can try to
hold onto the memories
of her before the disease
takes them all away.
And, meanwhile, the two
teens are falling in love
for the first time, because my
grandmother was 19 years old
when she married my grandfather.
And I think about that fact,
because I think about --
regardless of how we feel about
those laws, or those customs,
or those traditions, or
whatever it might be,
I think about the capacity of
young folks to fall in love.
That's a real thing
that I want to honor.
There are some of you in
this room who might be teens
who are falling in love.
Awesome! I'm excited for you!
It's a great feeling!
And as my grandfather
told me one night,
when I was interviewing
him, as he was passing away
from Alzheimer's disease -- I
was trying to get his stories
of the sort of hard-scrabble
Irish immigrant stories
in western Massachusetts.
I really wanted to write a
historical novel, you see.
But that's not what he
wanted to talk about.
All he wanted to talk
about every night
as I interviewed him, as
his mind wandered around,
and he lost his place
in his storytelling --
all he wanted to talk
about was my grandmother,
and how they fell in love.
He'd get lost in his stories,
and he'd reach over,
and he'd hold my arm.
And he'd say, "Brendan, this
is why I love your grandmother.
This is why I love
your grandmother.
She was the rock."
And so I thought about -- well,
I have to write this story
about what it means to try to
talk about love near the end
of life, and how maybe the
one thing you want to talk
about are those moments
when you first learned how
to fall in love.
Those moments where you
first learned what it meant
to open your heart
up to somebody else,
and to have them open
their heart up to you.
And so, The Last True Love
Story is that dual narrative
of trying to hold onto
love at the end of life,
and what it means to be falling
in love for the first time,
and travelling across
the country.
But love, as -- I really
appreciate your introduction
so much, because so
often, people want to say,
"Brendan writes about
social justice."
And yes, I do, and I care about
that, but I think at the first
of social justice is love.
And so, I so appreciate that
introduction, because as I begin
to talk about these next
two books, I want folks
to understand that
the place I'm speaking
from is a place of love.
Because the next
book that I wrote,
though it was published before
The Last True Love Story ,
I co-wrote with Jason Reynolds,
and it's called All
American Boys .
And I'm stoked to be a part
of that book and that project,
because as I was a high-school
teacher in New York City,
and I was looking around at
-- trying to think about --
how do I engage my classroom in
a more race-conscious fashion?
How do I adjust my
curriculum to begin to think
about being race-conscious,
as opposed to that distorted
disease of colorblindness?
I was looking around for
texts that would talk
about white privilege, and what
it meant for a teen who's white,
like me, to begin to process
what that privilege means.
And I was having a
hard time, actually,
finding a novel about that.
And as Jason and I were --
we were friends at the time
already before we started
working on the book, and as
we were thinking about the --
you know, we were talking
about writing a book together,
and talking about
what it would mean
to write a race-conscious book.
We thought a lot about what
it meant to then try to write
from an authentic
experience of each
of our own individual
cultural experiences.
And I want to explain to you why
I think that's important before
I explain why I think
tradition's important.
Because Jason and I, as
probably many of you know,
have had an amazing opportunity
to travel around the country
and talk to kids all
across the country.
We've talked to more than 50,000
young people around the country
to tell them about our
book, All American Boys ,
about two boys, one
black, one white.
Both of whom go to the same high
school, live in the same town,
are going to the same
Friday-night party,
stop at the same corner store
on the way to that party.
And at that corner store, Rashad
Butler, the young black boy,
is brutalized by a white police
officer, and Quinn Collins,
the young white boy,
witnesses this event,
and knows the police officer.
The police officer's a
father figure for him.
And the story is about how
these two teens then process
that experience afterwards, and
process it with their families,
and process it in
their community,
their high school.
Jason and I were thinking
a lot about the speech
that Martin Luther King,
Jr. gave at Grosse Pointe High
School in 1968, where he spoke
about two Americas
living side-by-side.
We thought about how All
American Boys would talk
about how that's so true today,
two Americas living
side-by-side.
We might, in fact, talk
about the multiple Americas
that are living side-by-side.
But again, this comes
from a place of love.
To actually talk about the
truth of what's happening
in our lives is important,
and it's really important
for young folks.
Because they're experiencing
it, and to shelter them
from it is our own problem of
censorship, because we're afraid
of the world that we have
failed to do better to shape.
They're living in the world that
we've failed to shape better.
So we deserve -- they
deserve our strength
to give them the real
stories of their lives.
As Jason and I traveled
around talking
about All American Boys --
I'll share this with
you for one moment,
because sometimes people talk
to me and say, "Hey, Brendan,
you know, it's really
hard to hear you talk
about white privilege so often."
Oh, my God [laughter].
There are so many reasons that
that is demented [laughter].
But one of the things that I
think is really important for me
to share with you all --
and then I'm going to
get into Tradition .
Because I think this
is the lead-in --
is that in one conversation
Jason and I were providing
for a school, at the
end of the presentation,
as so often is the case,
a number of the students
of color come and
speak to Jason.
A number of the white students
come speak to me, and at the end
of this particular presentation,
I was left alone in the room
with a white supremacist.
And I was having
this conversation
with a white supremacist,
as she was talking to me
about how she didn't
believe in white privilege.
And I won't get into
all the particulars,
because we don't have time
for it today, but the issue --
the first thing I was
wondering, in fact, was --
what are the gun laws in
this particular state?
Because it's terrifying to
think about that, and to think
about all the students of color
who were in that community
with a white supremacist,
who's out-and-out,
and feels emboldened enough to
come speak to me afterwards --
brave enough, doesn't feel
threatened in any way.
And I thought about our
conversation quite a bit,
and I thought a lot about
Brendan Kiely, white boy,
and how easy it was for me
to want to distance myself
from her, and say, "Well, I'm
not that kind of white person."
I wouldn't want to be
that kind of white person.
I would never want
to be associated
with that kind of white person.
And she was doing
the same thing to me.
She didn't want to be
associated with me.
She wanted to distance
herself from me.
But if that white
supremacist and I walk
onto an elevator together,
walk into a bank together,
walk into a grocery store
together, walk into any
of these public spaces together,
the experience that she
and I have walking in side
by side is so similar.
Whereas -- and I know Jason
doesn't mind if I share this.
When Jason and I walk into a
space together, when we walk
into an elevator together, when
we walk into a bank together,
when we walk into a grocery
store together, the experience
that he and I are having
are very different.
That's white privilege, and
to think about denying that is
to be denying a truth of
our cultural experience.
To deny those truths
and to tell kids
that doesn't exist is a lie
I will not participate in.
I write for kids,
because I care about them.
I love them.
I was a teacher for many years.
I miss it.
I want to get back in the
classroom, because I feel
like I miss my time with them.
Because they're bold
enough to ask the questions
that sometimes us older
folks are too afraid to ask.
And I tell that story to you
all about my time on the road
with Jason, because as I begin
to think about Tradition ,
and to tell you a little bit why
I wanted to write Tradition ,
I want you to hold that
notion of privilege
in your minds for a moment.
Because there's another
privilege
that I want to grapple with.
I want to grapple with my white
privilege every single day,
because there's no point that I
arrive at where I understand it.
There's no point that I arrive
at where I understand the
impact of racism in America.
It's more that I have to be
committed -- because I'm white,
I have to be committed every
day to try to do something
to be anti-racist,
to do something
to address what it means to
be a white person in America.
Because the minute I don't do
that, I'm succumbing to all
that privilege, and
all that it offers,
and all the harm that it causes.
I have to work against it.
But likewise, I think about
how I was taught to be a man,
and I think about
our world today.
And I think about how often I've
heard people say things like --
when a young woman is maybe
saying, "I've had enough
of these jokes in the
hallway," I've heard people say,
"Can't you just take a joke?"
I think about that,
because, again,
as I think to my grandmother's
line about a listening heart,
and what it means to
have a listening heart,
I think about how
we, as a society,
could do a better
job listening to many
of the folks in our society.
I think about me as a man who
could do a better job listening
to the women in my life.
As I listen to my wife tell
me stories about how --
where we live in New
York City, there's a lot
of construction around
where we live.
If she walks two
blocks this way,
it's all new buildings going up.
If she walks two
blocks this way,
it's all new buildings going up.
And as she walks by, so
often, she gets the catcalls.
If she walks by, so often, she
gets comments, or whistles.
Now, when I walk by, none
of that happens, right?
In fact, more often than not,
the construction
workers are looking
down at their phones
or whatever.
Now, it's not just
construction workers.
That would be way too
easy, just to throw
that out there and let that go.
Because my grandmother -- she,
too, has a story she shared
with me, one that I listened to.
She talked about what it meant
to join the workforce right
as she graduated
from high school.
My grandmother was
the valedictorian
of her high school.
It's amazing to me.
So think about this -- from
a small town in Pennsylvania.
When my grandmother got
her first job after that,
she worked at a doctor's office.
In that doctor's office,
there was a doctor
who would take the youngest,
newest female employee
of that office with him
to whatever conference he
was going to, travelling away
to some conference
somewhere else in the country.
And my grandmother
told me this story,
because she said she felt
really lucky that one
of the other women in the
office had shared that with her,
and said, "If he
invites you, don't go.
If he invites you, don't go.
That doctor -- don't
go with him."
But think about all the
women before my grandmother
who hadn't been warned.
And I think about that,
listening to those
stories, to those truths.
When I sat down to
write Tradition --
I sat down to write Tradition
-- I began writing it in 2015.
2015, some of you
may remember --
Emma Sulkowicz graduated
from Columbia University.
For those of you who don't
remember who Emma Sulkowicz was,
Emma Sulkowicz was assaulted --
sexually assaulted on the campus
of Columbia University.
The university didn't
want to talk about it.
The university really didn't
want to embrace the story
in the way that she
wanted them to embrace it,
to recognize the harm, the
truth of that experience.
And so, in an act of
defiance and protest,
she dragged her mattress
around campus.
Some of you may remember
those images
of this enormously courageous
young woman dragging her
mattress around campus.
And in 2015, she
dragged her mattress
up onto the graduation
stage in an act of defiance,
in an act to say, "I
will not be silenced.
My story will not go unheard."
That's tremendous
strength and courage,
and I also don't think we should
be burdening her with that need
to have to do that, right?
What if we were just
better listeners?
What if we embraced
our listening hearts?
I think about that,
because I think
about how I was raised
to be a man.
I think about how,
when I was growing up,
and I was in high school,
I had a guidance counselor
at my school, my high
school, who came into class
in ninth grade to say, 'Hey,
I'm going to teach you guys --
" because I went to an
all-boys high school --
"I'm going to teach you guys
how to be better scholars.
Going to teach you
how to be better --
have better study habits.
Let me tell you a
little anecdote
that I always share
with the young men.
Families would often invite
me to come into their house,
and take a look at how
their sons are studying
or not studying, and I
would give them tips.
And so, I went into
this one house one day,
and I went upstairs.
And the kid's doing his
homework in his bedroom, and --
" I'm not going to go on to
finish the story in his voice,
because I don't want
to repeat the words.
But the gist of it is this.
He began to tell us how this
student wasn't studying,
but looking out the window
and ogling the girls'
cross-country team
as they ran by in the street.
But the man didn't
just tell the story.
He acted it out.
He pantomimed what that
experience might be.
He caricatured the
act of ogling.
That guidance counselor of mine
wasn't teaching me how to study.
He was teaching me how
to be a misogynist.
to objectify women.
And I think about
that, because think
about the forward trajectory
of those kinds of cues,
about how often young men are
given these kinds of cues.
When we talk about male
privilege, when we talk
about toxic masculinity,
that's not a made-up thing.
It's not a myth.
The preponderance of those
kinds of cues are devastating.
They're devastating because the
ultimate result could be harmful
for young women, and
women of all ages,
and they can also be
harmful to young men.
Because the young -- they
rob all of these young men
of the opportunity to
become their full --
the full human that they can be.
And I wanted to write
about that.
I wanted to write about
the strong young women
who are standing up to
the misogyny of our world,
and the young men who
maybe want to listen,
but haven't been
told how to yet.
They don't have the
models to yet.
I think about that teacher who
taught me how to objectify women
and ogle women, because I think
about that same high school
when I was a senior -- we were
preparing for the senior prom.
And the school allowed a
tuxedo rental company to hang
up posters around the school,
and these posters were
all the same image.
It was three boys in tuxedoes
from the tuxedo rental company,
and it was young -- one
young woman in a prom dress.
And the three boys were
around the young woman.
The young woman was
tipped upside down,
so that her head
was on the ground
and her legs were in the air.
She was leaning against
a surfboard,
and two of the boys each had a
hand around one of her ankles.
I don't -- I hope I don't have
to explain the subtext
of that message.
But to a young man who's been
taught over and over and over
and over and over again how
to ogle and objectify women,
the message seems pretty
clear that prom equals sex,
and you're entitled to it.
That kind of messaging,
I think, is destructive.
It's horrible, right?
I'm not promoting this.
I'm being honest, just
like I am when I'm talking
about what it means to have
white privilege, just like I am
to say, "Look, when that
white supremacist and I walk
into an elevator
together, we don't --
we have a similar experience.
We share a privilege."
Well, likewise, guys, we
have to think about reflect
on what our privileges are.
You have to think
about and reflect
on how we have been too often
taught to be misogynists,
and what effect that
has in our culture.
When I sat down to write
Tradition , I wanted to write
about those two voices
that I was saying before.
Because if I'm going to
write about love, right,
I want to write about
the love that it takes
to have the courage to stand
up and say something about it,
as so many women have
been saying for so long.
I think about how we talk
about the Me Too movement,
and I'm very grateful
that Tradition has been called
A Separate Peace for the Me
Too generation.
I really appreciate that very
much, but I can't stand up here
and talk about that
without thinking
about the Me Too movement.
And how, while I was
introduced to it originally
because of Hollywood, in fact,
Tarana Burke, a black women
from the Bronx, started Me
Too more than a decade ago.
And I think about how people
have been talking about this --
women have been talking
about this for so long,
and I want to honor the Emma
Sulkowiczs of the world.
I want to honor the
Tarana Burkes of the world
by writing Jules
Deveraux's half of this book.
This is a book told
in two voices --
Jules Devereaux and
James Baxter.
James Baxter is a boy.
James Baxter -- part of the
inspiration for his story --
that same year, in 2015,
as we moved into 2016,
you may remember a
presidential campaign.
You may remember, during
that presidential campaign,
the "Hollywood Access" tapes.
And you may remember that, on
those "Hollywood Access" tapes,
we heard Donald Trump's
disgustingly violent language,
attitude, and behavior
towards women exposed
for us all to hear.
No one can say it didn't happen.
It happened.
We heard it.
We heard that, and there was
a lot of chatter in the world
of media about -- oh, that's
just locker-room talk.
Don't get over --
worked up about that.
That's just -- can't
you take a joke?
Or, it doesn't really
mean anything.
It doesn't have any effect.
Well, look at the
news this week.
It has effects.
And locker-room talk
is something
that I was really accustomed
to as a three-sport
athlete growing up.
I know about that locker-room
talk, but also, after I heard
and saw the "Hollywood
Access" tape, I saw boys --
a photo of a boys' football
team in Portland, Oregon.
This boys' football
team all were wearing
"Wild Feminist" t-shirts, and
the caption below the photo was,
"Not in our locker room.
Not in our locker room.
Not in our locker room."
Right?
[ Applause ]
And so, James Baxter -- the
other half of this book --
I wrote James Baxter for
all those boys out there
who are saying, "Not in our
locker room," for all the boys
who are willing to listen
to those other boys and say,
"Not in our locker room,"
and to join all the
women who've been saying,
"Enough is enough is enough."
We can do better, and I believe
books can help us get there.
I believe in books, because --
I'll share this one
last anecdote,
and they'll open
up for a quick Q&A.
When I was in 10th grade,
I remember reading
Frankenstein .
I remember reading Frankenstein
with Mr. Reilly [assumed
spelling], one of my
favorite teachers,
because I remember a scene
in the novel Frankenstein
where Dr. Frankenstein's
creation is running
into a village.
And the villagers are all
screaming at the creation,
screaming and saying, "We
don't -- " you know, basically,
the subtext is, we
don't know you.
You scare us because
we don't know you.
And they're yelling, you know,
phrases at him and whatnot,
and chasing him out
of the village.
And I will never forget reading
that scene in class, looking up,
terrified, at Mr. Reilly.
You're my Mr. Reilly
right now [laughter].
Looking up at Mr. Reilly, and
kind of mumbling to myself,
but saying, "When am I
one of those villagers?
When am I chasing someone
away from the cafeteria table?
When am I chasing
someone out of the room?
When am I not listening
to people
who are asking to be heard?"
I think books can change
perspectives, can change lives.
In that moment, I
thought a lot more,
though I didn't have the
words for it at the time.
I thought a lot more
about how I wanted to work
on my listening heart,
and not be one
of those villagers chasing the
creation out of the village.
And so, because there's
not a lot of time left,
I do want to open it up for Q&A.
And before I do, I just also
want to say thank-you to all
of you for listening, because it
takes listening in order for us
to have a conversation.
So if you want to now talk
to me, and I'll listen,
come to the signing
line, and I'll listen
to you all you want [laughter].
But we have about -- a little
less than 10 minutes left.
So, like, let's open
it up to Q&A if we can.
But thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
And it's hard for me
to see, so if you get
to a microphone,
just start talking.
>> If you weren't an author,
what would you do in your life?
>> Brendan Kiely: Thanks!
If I weren't an author,
what would I do?
So I'm really grateful to be
an author, and in other talks,
I talk a lot more about
the writing process.
But given the space we're in,
I wanted to make sure I
said what I had to say.
The truth is, I called
my mother when I --
after my first day of teaching,
and I had many jobs before that.
And I called my mother,
and I said, "Ma,
I finally found a job I like."
[Laughter] I love teaching,
and if I'm not an author,
if I can find a way to
go back into teaching
with a more regular schedule,
I'll go back to that.
Because for me, teaching
is a social experience
in which I'm learning along
with all the students,
and I want to do that more.
I want to do a lot less
one person on a stage,
and a lot more group
working together [laughter].
So thank you.
>> Hi. Last time I saw you,
you were wearing that t-shirt,
and I thought, I like this guy.
>> Brendan Kiely: Wild Feminist?
>> Yes.
>> Brendan Kiely: Nice!
>> And I feel like we're all
friends now, because I come talk
to you after every
lecture that I see.
But I just wanted to
share that when --
I teach in a middle school, and
when my son was there, I said,
"You know, of all the places
in the middle school I would --
don't ever want to be in
the room is during FLE,"
which is what we call
the sex ed in the boys --
they split it, you know.
And I said, "I can just
imagine what the room is like."
And my son -- he's a very
sort of tender, kind person.
And I said all that
innuendo, and the jokes --
and he said, "Yeah, it's worse
when the teachers do it."
And it just broke my heart,
and I'm just so pleased
that you've written this book.
So I just want to thank you.
>> Brendan Kiely: Thank you.
Thank you for sharing that.
>> If you love teaching so much,
what made you decide
to become an author?
>> Brendan Kiely: Well,
that is a great question.
When I went back to the school
where I was a teacher --
Jason and I went to
do a presentation
about All American Boys there.
And there was a student who
stood up and said, "Come back!"
And I was -- like, that
was an awesome moment.
I felt really, you know,
grateful, and it was hard to do
at the time because of the
demands of travelling around
and talking about the
books and whatnot.
But the reason why I left is
because I -- I mean,
I love books.
I love teaching.
I love Jason.
I love travelling
around with one
of the closest friends
of my life.
I love that guy.
But I also love my wife,
and Jessie, my wife,
who's also an author -- and she
had an opportunity to go work
for one year in Italy.
And so, she was going
to go to Italy,
and I was going to go with her.
And so, that meant I had
to leave the classroom
so I could go be with her,
and that's how things
got started, actually.
So I'm going to find a way to
try to bring it all together,
but I went because I
love my wife [laughter].
Yes?
>> What do you like, and
what are the challenges,
of co-writing a book?
>> Brendan Kiely: Nice!
So what do I like?
Aside from only having
to write half a book,
which is pretty cool -- so,
to make a sports analogy,
which I know is wild --
but I still love sports.
I don't -- I mean, this is
a book that has, you know,
a discussion about problems
in some sports culture,
but I love sports,
and I'm not going
to throw sports under the bus.
When I played basketball,
one of the best feelings
in the world is on a fast break,
and being able to pass the ball,
and you know that
person's going to be there
without even having to look.
And while co-writing All
American Boys with Jason,
we felt that experience,
being able to pass the ball,
and knowing the other
person's going to be there.
That's a remarkable experience
as an artist, because so much
of your time is spent alone,
and in agony [laughter].
And to have a friend to share
that with is tremendous,
and again, if we're going to
talk about listening hearts --
if you're going to be writing
about stuff that's really
important, and really serious,
and really hard, it's pretty
powerful to have someone
that you love with whom
to share that experience.
So collaborating is amazing.
Yeah?
>> With all your social
changes, does it increase
or decrease in your faith?
>> Brendan Kiely:
Wow [laughter].
That is going to be the last --
second-to-last question,
thankfully.
The -- I have a complicated
relationship with faith,
and it's much more
than I can say
in the one minute I have left.
But I will say this -- that I
see no reason not to have faith
in humanity, and there are
many of us that find our faith
in humanity through a faith
in another, higher power.
And right now, I'm choosing
to see the higher power that's
within social groups who
decide to work together,
and listen to each other,
and make the world a
place that's more just
and more equitable.
That's where I have faith,
but faith requires work.
And so therefore, if I
want to believe in it,
have faith in that community,
I have to be an active
participant in that community.
I can't just want it to exist.
I have to work for it.
And so, for me, any question
of faith is a question of work,
and I want to believe
in that community,
so I want to help
be a part of it.
So, thanks.
Last question?
>> Over here.
>> Brendan Kiely: Yeah?
>> I just want to thank you all
for saving the best
for last [laughter].
But --
>> Brendan Kiely: Yes!
See, I have faith!
>> -- yeah, sorry, my heart's
beating really fast [laughter].
But do you think it would
impact a lot on the news if --
and help stop victim-blaming,
while we watch the news,
to stop using passive voice,
and instead using active voice?
Like, for example, I remember
once in All American Boys ,
it was like -- it was like --
no, but, like, in any act of
violence on the news, I mean,
like -- like, for
example, it was like --
I'm sorry, I'm really nervous.
>> Brendan Kiely: No,
no, no, no, keep going.
You're awesome.
>> Okay. It was, like, Rashad
was beaten, but it's like, no,
the cop -- sorry --
the cop beat Rashad.
>> Brendan Kiely: Yes.
>> You know?
And, like, do you think it
would help us a lot to, like --
to help stop victim
blaming, and instead, like,
see the real picture, and,
like, be truthful, not neutral,
like Amanpour's phrase?
>> Brendan Kiely: So I -- you're
framing this as a question,
but I hear it as a statement,
and I agree with you.
I'm with you.
No, I'm serious.
I'm not saying this to be coy.
I'm saying, I think what you're
saying is really important,
right?
So I'm backing you up on that.
Because absolutely,
I agree with you.
We have to be -- accountability
is in the active voice.
And if we want to work
on that community,
if we want to be active
participants in that community,
we have to be bold and
speak in the active voice.
And that's why I have to talk
about the privilege that I have
as a thing that is a part of
my everyday experience, right?
I have to -- we have to
speak in the active voice.
That is so awesome that
you brought that up,
and what a great way to end.
Let's go out there
and read, be inspired,
and then go do something
about it all.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]